talk about sales and selling the biggest
thing like people here it's like this
Antiquated notion of like you know
manipulating people into buying
something they truly don't want need or
desire uh tricking people into buying
more than they need you know that's
typically what I thought sales was until
I started to actually study it and and
frankly sales by definition my
definition is the quickest quickest way
between a problem and a solution and
there's no way to there's no better way
to put it than that welcome to 20 minute
leaders just sit back relax and learn
from the leaders of today it's a journey
each one is different unique inspiring
let's get started
[Music]
20 minute leaders is a proud supporter
of Make-a-Wish Israel and Tech to peace
and is in proud collaboration with
secret Court Ventures J Ventures
Riverside Femme Fusion VC Birthright
Excel J impact leap Google for startups
and hippo and in media partnership with
ctek hello hello and welcome to 20
minute leaders today we're going to be
talking about Cairo practice but from a
different lens meet Dr Daniel Bay the
CEO of close for Cairo a provocative and
enterprising business consulting company
from an unlikely industry Chiropractic
he is an author speaker and thought
leader on the subject of sales and
marketing in the modern world and has
changed the Antiquated Notions most have
about the subject he has tackled The
Dilemma business owners struggle with
when it comes to building a business at
the expense of altruism and vice versa
although he serves the Chiropractic
industry exclusively his lessons cross
all boundaries and are sought by many
other businesses and organizations be
warned however Dr Dan's style is quick
and straight from the hip his level of
Candor in his interviews speaking
engagements and broadcasts usually live
as listeners wondering what he will say
next while grading teeth he holds no
punches and does not sugarcoat anything
reluctantly he has been asked to tone it
down but has declined and he is a 2 000
USA national silver medalist in fencing
I love the setup that you have and and
uh we're gonna we're gonna have a really
interesting conversation not just about
business and about entrepreneurship and
about sales or about the industry that
you're in which is a definitely
non-convert not not the conventional
industries that I get to interview on
this show and and your own personal
journey is it's pretty fascinating one
on its own and I'd love to start off the
episode both both by understanding you a
little bit better on who you are and I
want to take it all the way around 2000
uh you know you're an athlete also not a
traditional mainstream athlete tell me a
little bit about that
sure I mean that kind of feeds into how
I got into my own industry and
so um in high school I was a a fencer so
um and in my bio I usually say that
certainly does not help my social life
yeah and um
but I got really good at it at a pretty
young age and I got recruited uh to play
at fence in college
and I fixed the college
excuse me fence college and then
um to my junior year or my senior year
in college
um I was the silver medalist medalist at
the 2000 U.S Nationals so that's my
claim to fame
uh but before that if you back it up um
the only reason I got to that level of
competition was because I've got an
injury that I didn't fall I had no car
accidents nothing I just had this injury
in my my in my pelvis and my lower back
and I was in school at Boston University
and you probably already know for the
folks who are listening to this in North
America uh Boston is like the medical
Mecca the smartest people in the world
in terms of healthcare all live and
reside in the Boston area and I probably
visited about six or seven other uh
Healthcare professionals uh orthopedic
surgeons
um X Y and Z and no one can really
figure out my problem and uh ultimately
I was left really in a really bad place
um I was very depressed I couldn't do
what I loved and anyone who's been in
that position probably understand and
then I stumbled onto a chiropractor
um online at Starbucks ordering a drink
and the only thing that made me happy at
the time was a Frappuccino so I went to
get hobbled over to the Starbucks I got
a Frappuccino and the guy in back of me
I started asking me questions about why
I'm you know 19 years old and I'm
limping long story short he invited me
into his office he worked on me and it
was literally probably one of the few
miraculous moments in my life because
you got to understand I've been
suffering with this problem for over
like two months and in college at two
months to make the lineup and also be
ready and not lose my scholarship there
was a lot riding on it was forever and
the fact that he took me for one week
and I was back with my team practicing
uh preparing for Nationals um was the
Oracle that I experienced so
yeah and so obviously that's that
incited a whole nother career change I'm
like oh my gosh like what is this
staying prior to that it's a
chiropractic what the heck is that this
is like witchcraft like people what I
don't understand like how does this
whole thing work and so that um was
incredibly curious time in my life and
then of course I ended up uh going to
chiropractic school and the rest is
history
so well what do you identify now talking
to someone you know a business
entrepreneurial uh landscape you're
looking now at at the you know the
market what are the different issues
that you're noticing and obviously this
is gonna you know feed into what you're
doing at close for Cairo close for Cairo
what what what's happening here why were
you in such a in a difficult state where
obviously you're you're looking for help
and help is right literally next to you
and you don't necessarily know to ask
for it yourself
yeah so um
did that you know that was interesting
because the conversation I had with Dr
leader and I'll just I I'll never forget
him was a conversation I had with him
not about
the service or the product of
Chiropractic and he could have been
selling I don't know a pill he could he
could have really been representing
anything but the reason that I in my
state really connected with him was
because
he identified with one of my deepest
wants needs and Desires in that
particular moment so fast forward I
became a chiropractor I started
practicing and it was a very another
depressing moment in my life such a
downer it gets better I promise and the
reason it was so bad is because when I
graduated school I was so enthusiastic
about sharing the stuff that I have
learned and and and I just all I really
wanted to do was help other people
experience what I experienced as a young
man but when I got into the practice
what I realized is that I was getting
Relentless no's out the rejection was
overwhelming Michael I mean I couldn't
understand it how could people say no to
this thing that is so awesome okay that
I know how to deliver and I'm
enthusiastic about it how could these
people be saying no all day long and so
the the challenge there was is this is
that for some reason the people that I'm
explaining this to the people that I
want to experience what I have to offer
are saying no and I couldn't understand
why that was and it wasn't because of
the product of the service because
there's other colleagues that were
crushing it but me I'm sitting in an
empty office I can't feed my family I
can't I remember I couldn't even afford
to live in New York City at the time
couldn't even afford a bus fare at times
because I was so broke I was so
enthusiastic and and that was another
very depressing time in my life because
at that point I thought about leaving
the career because I couldn't make a
living so that was the challenge until I
realized the biggest problem I had
Michael at that point wasn't the fact
that I wasn't good at what I did
technically it was the fact that I could
not sell this thing and when you talk
about sales and selling the biggest
thing like people here it's like this
Antiquated notion of like you know
manipulating people into buying
something they truly don't want need or
desire uh tricking people into buying
more than they need you know that's
typically what I thought sales was until
I started to actually study it and and
frankly Sam sales by definition my
definition is the quickest quickest way
between a problem and a solution and
there's no way to there's no better way
to put it than that
so what what is this what is the
experience that you've had as you're
thinking through taking people who are
naturally are you know they're you know
you're you're providing a gift your
service is a gift to somebody else in
Need You know it's uh it's it's not the
most trivial thing to sell and you're
taking them through a process of
learning how to sell it which is almost
I think it feels like in terms of the
way the industry has shaped itself is
sort of you know counter to the actual
doing right I mean there's some
perception that selling means that
you're not necessarily the one doing you
know the actual service you're just sort
of Eliza but here you're saying this is
a critical a critical piece of it how
how you know put this puzzle together
for me because I feel like it's coming
together and I really want to get it
yeah so that's a great Point Michael
because in traditional sales
professionals you're a liaison you're
right uh between uh the customer and the
Fulfillment side right so how many times
have we talked to a salesperson and they
they close and they they um they get our
business and then we never see them
again because now we're with a different
company or for our department for them
to fulfill that particular product or
service right
for most entrepreneurs though uh and me
included especially in healthcare or in
in the service industry you are the
sales person and you're also the
fulfiller of that particular product and
service you're the you're the same
people you're the same person so that
presents a challenge and I'll tell you
why Michael because
we are almost too invested in our
product and service
where we take things way too personally
where we lose objectivity and because of
that we lose perspective now one of the
things that we teach all of our clients
and this this crosses all boundaries I
don't care if you're selling Healthcare
or or you know a a a drone for kids or
it doesn't really matter what all people
the the biggest challenges is that
because we're so invested personally in
what we're doing
is that we lose perspective of our
Prospect so we always say always be in
the perspective of your prospect and if
you're too worried about your own stuff
and you're too worried about being
rejected you're too worried about you
know making you look yourself look so
good and patting your resume and making
yourself look so attractive that it
never leaves in a bandwidth for you to
really understand what the other person
truly wants needs and desires and if you
if you don't have that perspective I'm
sorry you don't have a chance
okay ever in getting that other person
to see you as a solution to their
problem or for the other person to
actually want what you have to offer
so how much of the the sales that or the
techniques the strategies for making it
work how much of it is is tailored to
chiropractors versus how much of it is
more general you know skill sets that
would be relevant and could be could be
you know Associated or transitioned to
any any industry or any product
that's a great question in the beginning
Michael I thought
it was only specific to my industry
because I didn't know anything else
then I come to find out and we've been
doing this for over 12 years
um we come to find out that the majority
of what we're talking about
uh shares the same Concepts as and
selling any other product or service
worldwide whether it be a product or
service or anything in between so I'm
going to say 90 of what we're talking
about are skills that can be used in any
other industry because I learned it from
other Industries because you know one of
the things that I had a problem with it
was in my industry there was no one
teaching it because the whole entire
industry was so I guess infantile in
terms of their their business Acumen
where they never talked about sales
because sales was a bad thing so that's
how I grew up in this so I couldn't find
it inside my own industry so I had to go
elsewhere so where did I look I looked
at the top you know when you think about
people who know how to sell we're
talking real estate talking automobile
we're talking Finance of financial
instruments we're talking all those
other things uh pharmaceutical sales
pharmaceutical equipment sales so I had
to go to those Industries to understand
how this whole thing works and we can
talk through some of the basic
strategies and and some of once we get
through it you're going to be like man
that is so common sense yes it is this
thing called selling is so simple and
unfortunately we over complicate this
and anytime you over complicate selling
it's like over complicating a first date
you know what I'm saying like at a first
date if you talk too much you're
probably not going to get a second date
right Michael if you talk about yourself
too much you're not going to get a
second date what is the best way to
ensure a second date you know from the
male perspective I can I can only speak
from that it's number one shut up stop
talking number two be inquisitive be
curious and number three ask the
appropriate questions that allows the
other person to open up to you more than
they would open up to anybody else and
that's the anatomy of the initial
interaction in any sales conversation I
don't care what industry you're in
industry interesting
I like that but I like that very much
how have you fine-tuned your own
business over tell me about the growth
of clothes for Cairo as as you grow it
yourself because you know
Mo both with the you know the nature of
the show you know the I'm really curious
to you about how your your personal jury
Journey evolved with this company and
how you've grown with your
understandings you've built your thesis
around what product you're personally
offering it sounds like you've had quite
a few step functions in your own Journey
tell me a little bit about the growth of
clothes for Cairo and what this company
is all about
sure so um you know like like any
business venture I think we can all
agree it evolves over time in the
beginning it was just a way for me to
share knowledge that other my colleagues
did not have so it was very casual and
we used to teach them this is what you
do this is how you do it
and um one of the things that I realized
over the course of the last 10 12 years
is that
um
especially entrepreneurialism and and
you know
um uh you know
self-development personal development
there's a lot of
just lip service there's a and I hate to
say it this way like you know when you
go on Facebook or Instagram you know you
see those little posts with the little
quotes on there and they all sound good
you know it's like oh yeah I gotta do
that or oh yeah that sounds really good
and it's and it ends there you know it
just inspires you to no end there's no
purpose in this inspiration there's no
purpose in this positive mental attitude
or or being being you know um uh having
a a a good mental game and this is the
analogy I want to give and if you're if
you're a golfer let's say
um I don't care how many Instagram posts
that you read about having positive
mental attitude or how many books you
read on how to be better with you
attitude if you don't have the
fundamentals of the game of golf you
will never ever ever Tee It Up at the US
Open or at the Masters like the odds are
infinitesimally it's practically
impossible for me and you to Tee It Up
at the Masters with world-class golfers
just by thinking positively and in my
profession like that's been rampant it's
like oh everything's gonna be fine if
you just are positive
and that drove me nuts I wanted to bang
my head against the mic every time I
hear that because people who are saying
that are lacking the fundamental skills
that you need in terms of sales and
business and I don't care how positive
you are you're never gonna get there and
so what we did was in terms of our
teaching is listen
we got to start somewhere and what we
got we have to do is we have to teach a
framework and and this is important
because Michael listen sales has always
been esoteric it's always been a little
bit like you know oh this is kind of how
you do it there's never a formulated
structure that was dedicated to a
particular industry so what we did was
we took all of the teachings that we've
learned from other Industries and
adapted it to the Chiropractic industry
what that means is this is the first
question you ask this is how you ask it
these are the these are the the possible
responses you'll get and this is how you
respond now that seems very scripted and
it's very
um you know in a box but I gotta tell
you something if you don't know the
fundamentals or the fundamentals or the
fundamentals you will never ever reach
the art level that you will in anything
that you do okay let's take golf for
example yeah grip stance ball position
all fundamentals boring scripted every
person who learns how to play golf
learns those fundamentals you want to
learn how to play piano you do scales
you do chords you learn the notes you
unders everyone who's learned piano a
certain classical way learned it the
same way what separates the person that
is actually in Carnegie Hall playing
piano and the person that's in their
room playing Twinkle Twinkle Little Star
what's the difference the biggest
difference is the fact that the person
who is making this art who is making
them their own knows the fundamentals so
inside out so rock solid that now they
put themselves into it and they actually
Express that thing as art as opposed to
the person who can't even play a scale
that wants to play A Carnegie Hall so
that's what we learned over the years
it's like we got to start with the
fundamentals of the fundamentals and the
fundamentals and it's boring sometimes I
get it
but wow if we can make it fun to learn
the fundamentals then that's the first
step you feel me
completely I mean I mean I just love
that analogy I mean I I
don't think I've ever thought of it that
way but it's uh it's quite remarkable
because it's definitely Trump and you're
looking at the way that you're you're
practicing and I play saxophone and I
play tennis and I'm looking at the way
that I started out and I was doing the
most boring things for the first three
four years right and I'm looking at the
way that I'm the way that I'm looking at
you know the the transitions that I've
made as a player as an athlete to to
bringing my own creativity to uh to
bringing my own self on the court and on
the stage the only way that I'm able to
do that is through the confidence both
both the confidence that I gained
learning the the fundamentals
but also understanding the rules of the
games that I can engage with the game in
a meaningful way and adapt as needed and
it's pretty and then the rules when you
need to right right yeah and uh
completely completely and that that's
really that's really amazing and I and
Daniel I really want to thank you for
for coming on and for sharing these uh
you know these insights with me and um
and I really really did love the
conversation and that that this last
note is definitely going to leave me
leave me hanging for a while uh thinking
about not just not just about
chiropractor about my own self but you
know everything that I also do you know
in running a company and in building
products I mean if they think this this
idea is spans far beyond sales or what I
do it's it's really sort of an
understanding that a lot of things you
have to get the fundamentals right in
order to become you know a key player in
it
absolutely wonderful Daniel thank you so
much I really appreciate it
Michael it was my pleasure uh for being
on here with you good luck with
everything that you're doing in the
future appreciate it thank you very very
much
[Music]